America America has a
[Music]
problem turine watch PG Lane 911 sler
look at my garages sink up get the genie
at the bottle and point it
matter it up
stin hey to complexity to learn me from
go my mama told me that the money out my
horoscope said I'm really my noodle I'm
troubling I'm puzzling it's a yes
America got a problem kicked up choosey
love that chose violence Universal
please don't play POS I'm a businessman
doing follow truthfully H be lying in my
rap song cuz I always F A mention I slap
homie his career didn't C no life
insurance hope day one fans got some
facts on them I'm a honor beehive let's
see why them D don't be fly they all CGI
you better get it off your chest like
breast reduction if she stress over you
she stress for nothing up a minute AI
got to practice cloning Krick the double
lra the ENC like the Ops
[Music]
need
got
de you a whole we for me I see you
watching I know you want it I know you
it
[Music]
it I
need you this like it you know that
booty going do what it want to can't hit
it one time I know you see on me now
coming
get 40 80 out the Trap hit it with the
rap put it on the map then be right
back call me you to get man with the r i
on my back G's on my Dash I'm I'm
bad I'm bad you can't get no
higher
this no cuz love don't get no
higher than this no
no grind but you know I grind when I
pull up the change of
mind when I step on the SC can't wait to
back it
up ain't enough I'm supplying my man I'm
in man soon as I just know I roll with
them goons in case you start acting
familiar this kind of love big business
SL you can't get no
higher
this no cuz love don't get no
higher than this no no no grind but you
know I grind when I pull up to change
your mind I pull your mind when I step
on the there can't wait to back it up
your ex a dope but it ain't enough I'm
supplying my man I'm in soon I just know
I with them goons in you start acting
familiar kind of love business
[Music]
I time see r on me now coming
get 40 80 out the trap with the rap put
it on the map be right
back call me
you man with the on my
[Music]
I'm
oh
my goodness y'all that was brutal um the
temperatures were below freezing here
today and those wind gusts you saw
behind me were reaching anywhere between
uh 15 to 20 mph and uh I'm told that it
topped out in some places in town at
like 40 mph so it was it was chilly it
was chilly out there not the most brutal
conditions that I've uh shot my yearly
Martin Luther King Jr day uh video but
uh wasn't that far away from it either
anyhow I hope you all appreciated
watching this video if you're interested
in grabbing a set of the sock po that I
was using in this one uh I got a promo
code for that it is Drex factor that
gets you a discount on your own set of
those wonderful fabric POI I'll leave a
link down in the description uh to where
you can pick up a set of those um yeah I
hope you all appreciated joining me for
my annual tradition of uh shooting a
video for Martin Luther King day um yeah
it's weird thing that kind of became a
habit and a ritual and I just why that
happened is kind of lost to the animals
of time but kind of glad that it is cuz
it's a nice yearly way for me to check
in and uh just see where I'm at with my
flow
um anyway so uh thanks should go out
because uh this video would not be
possible without the friends of the
channel big thanks go to uh dark monk
fire Mecca flow fests flow toys juggling
calling pyrro Tera light toys spinballs
and Ultra poy for helping to make the
videos on this channel possible you can
learn more about all these awesome
companies and the work they're doing to
support flow artists like yourself by
checking out the links that I have down
in the description of this video and
special thanks to the non- business
friend of the Channel Becca Becken thank
you so very much for supporting my
channel my work and my mission and
speaking of thank yous this video would
not be possible without uh my amazing
patreon supporters in particular I'd
love to give a shout out to my flow
patrons who are listed on screen now um
I would not be able to make these videos
were it not for my amazing patreon
supporters uh there's a bunch of other
things that I do now to bring money in
the door from doing private lessons to
live stream lessons um um but those of
you who are supporting me on patreon
make it possible for me to keep on
coming back and doing videos like this
one so if you're out there watching and
you'd love to see more videos like this
one you can make that happen by going to
patreon.com factor Po and signing up
there's a load of awesome rewards there
so go check that out please and thank
you finally if you'd like to check out
some of the flow videos that I've done
in years past on Martin Luther King Jr
day I will include a list a to a
playlist of uh those videos down in the
description as well as up on screen
thanks so much for watching I hope
you're warmer than I am today and I'll
see you with a new video real soon now
okay cool take care peace